[Music]
this is an exciting time for you it is
oh my god
how has life been for you since you've
run let it out there since you know the
public now knows you know like it's been
bittersweet that we've used that word a
lot because I think it was the right
decision for me and since it's happened
so many other opportunities that
presented themselves so it's reinforced
that it was the right idea but I'm I'm
I'm not losing a family because those of
it those women are doing my family
forever
but on Friday I'm gonna be a hot mess
for sure I'm really lucky to have had
this job for as long as I've had it in a
business where nothing is guaranteed let
alone not just six years on a show that
you love but with women that you love
it's it's extraordinary you mentioned so
many things coming your way obviously
directing Criminal Minds you've got just
just a lot how much can you do when
writing a movie
I'm co-writing two other movies
directing an episode of Criminal Minds
next month I'm going to be doing another
feature in the spring but I'm also
hoping to be a little bit more of a
person sleep more I don't know develop
some friendships it's a goal it's a goal
Julia had mentioned us that you there's
gonna be a new panel sitting in for you
as you mentioned that it might even be a
a male could there be a could there be a
man and they've done the town I think
they want the right person for the job
and I think what they have to replicate
which it's gonna be hard it's not just
the chemistry we had my first year but
the chemistry we have now after six
years on this show I think they're
forgiving and they're understanding I'm
they're never gonna be able to replace
me well I was gonna sit better you
easily want them to find somebody
amazing and I keep saying that like I
really want somebody great for you guys
you deserve it you've worked hard and I
love them and I love the show and I
wanted to continue to thrive as it
[Music]
you